What are your thoughts on IV vitamin C? Well IV vitamin C, I list as one of the cancer killers in my book, but it's one of, I don't know, what do we have?
100 cancer killers or 80 of them are something listed in chapter 5 of this book, so this is for a free download, it's a big book, it's like 5, 600 pages, so you can get it on Amazon, but it's a free download on our website.
So we look at vitamin C as one of those 80 possible cancer killers, so we don't see vitamin C as, oh my gosh, you got cancer, get out IV vitamin C right away, it can be a huge benefit for some people.
But it's just like anything, whether it be people therapy, whether it be an alternative therapy, whether it's IV vitamin C or it's mushrooms or whatever it is, what works for one person might not work for another person.
So how do I know that? Well again, in our clinic we test for that, but what are the ways that if you don't have that ability to test for that, if you're a believer you should be praying about what you should be doing, obviously.
But otherwise you just have to try things and see if it works for you.
How long should I try IV vitamin C before it's going to really change the cancer growth?
You know, give it a few months, see if that makes a difference. If you feel like you're really led to do IV vitamin C, stay on it.
You know that when anybody is going to deal with cancer it's usually a combination of multiple things that's going to affect that cancer to send you into remission.
IV vitamin C can be done along with chemotherapy. We typically recommend if you do IV vitamin C with chemotherapy you wait at least 48 to 72 hours after your use of the chemotherapy to do an IV vitamin C session.
Even though IV vitamin C, the argument is that vitamin C is an antioxidant and chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent so you're negating the effects of the chemotherapy if you're giving the chemotherapy which is a highly oxidizing agent to your body.
You want it to kill the cancer, it's a poison. And if you give IV vitamin C if that's an antioxidant, well you're negating the effects of the chemotherapy. If I'm going to go through the chemotherapy I want it to work.
But there's some studies out there that show high dose vitamin C in an IV form actually can work as an oxidizing agent.
So there's some argument there but still to be safe I had to keep that at least 48 hours away from chemotherapy so that you're not getting any antioxidant effect and negating the chemotherapy if you're choosing to do that because you want it to work.